allein für alle mit fernweh airline für
mid hw
werden präsentiert von swiss
ein gästehaus auf der insel bali
patricia und romano tschudi wollen aus
dem alltag ausbrechen familie folglich
sie sucht ihr glück in kanada in den
rocky mountains bauen sie ein holzfäller
unternehmen auf tobias bayer und michael
paris unendlich etwas eigenes eine
kleine bar aufwartete ventura
[Musik]
sid
sie haben verrät ist auch hier ein
scherz nicht zum glauben es nervt dicke
luft in kanada die holzernte maschine
von christian volk ist kaputt das
problem ist einfach dass wir zu hause
fahre zum laden haben wir nicht gemacht
komponenten und hochdruck fahrenheit zu
unterstützen zu unserer stunden ihnen
schlug verjagt und der riesen öle
sondern der samurai und grauenhaft und
modernen fußballs ohne dass nur zwei
jahren dauer zu unterstellen irgendwo
kaputt ich wechsle
das ist zwar ziemlich große schnüren die
sind irgendwann muss lachen als rubens
und jetzt haben wir gerade ganz da
kannst du nicht wechseln schade dass es
nicht im wald irgendwo im schnee vor dem
rathaus friede sei aber dass nach den
verlorenen tag musste christian und sein
mitarbeiter mirco im wald wieder
aufholen
und der nächste auftrag hat es in sich
in der letzten folge liegt die arbeit
für christian wie geschmiert doch
ehefrau simone haderte mit dem neuen
leben in clearwater patricia zog es
zurück zur tochter natascha in die
schweiz
zudem musste ein zweites standbein hier
das gästehaus geschlecht zurück unter
palmen zogen die buchungen jedoch
endlich an
[Musik]
letzte handgriffe aufwerte ventura nach
sechs wochen umbau konnten tobias und
michael rabba eröffnen
kassel
[Musik]
sie sehen die ersten gäste
tobias und michael versuchen sich ab
jetzt in ihren neuen rollen
sie haben an alles gedacht an fast alles
was fehlt ist zerstoßenes 1
[Musik]
die cocktails heute gehämmert und nicht
gerührt
[Musik]
bis vor ein paar wochen arbeitete tobias
beim bodenpersonal am flugplatz bern
belpmoos lebensgefährte michael verkauf
der herrenkleidung in tuben
[Musik]
na ja nicht so schlimm aber nicht da
jeder hat sich das aber nicht klar gegen
die initiative langer so michael sagt
meister werden haben muss ja lustig für
die mädels aus dem baltikum die
feuertaufe haben sie bestanden
[Musik]
die straßen sind geschmückt es ist
gelogen
die balinesen feiern die rückkehr der
geister ihrer vorfahren das gästehaus
von studis war in den letzten wochen
ausgebucht
nach einem schwierigen start nahm air
bed and breakfast langsam fahrt auf doch
dies gegen auf bäckerin sarah ist der
letzte gast für patrizier war die
sehnsucht nach tochter natascha zu groß
also nimmt oder h m sc p also irgendwie
das gefühl haben wir jetzt liebe und
deutlich stellen so irgendwie sind die
zweifel ob sie gesetzlich für romano
platzt ein lebenstraum
er wäre gerne hier geblieben der
fraktion diskutiert halb motto halbjahr
die haarfeinen option sich
schlussendlich das derzeit also so
bringt seinen namen
der pachtvertrag für das gästehaus endet
er ohnehin und auch die verhandlungen
über eine verlängerung sind gescheitert
sie konnten beim vermieter keinen
günstigeren preis durchsetzen
rückblickend fast ein glücksfall
ein teil der möbel geht an den nachbarn
dem vermieter wie romano nichts zurück
lassen sagt sie bemühe möbelzulieferer
aufbau und jetzt darf man sich drauf
aber ich verstand patricia wirklich weil
er wie gesagt immer wenn es umgekehrt
war war ich heilfroh wenn sie somit
reagieren und zwischenzeit nicht so mit
dem möbel tore ich sage es mal auto
finanzielle schaden wenn man damals auch
so sagen halte sich in grenzen
so ist nicht was sie hier nicht
loswerden packen schuh dies in einen
container
sie wollen es später in der schweiz
verkaufen
ok
[Musik]
in den rocky mountains ist
fingerspitzengefühl gefragt
[Musik]
30 tonnen müssen auf den tieflader
zentimetergenau
[Musik]
christian und seine männer machen sich
auf zu ihren speziellen auftragen ein
holzschlag in einem besonders
schwierigen an 30 kilometer von
clearwater entfernt
[Applaus]
für volks läuft das geschäft
mittlerweile haben sie fünf mitarbeiter
und zwei praktikanten über extra
angelegte schotterpisten rollen hier
täglich unzählige holzlaster
mit
[Musik]
das areal wieder der schweiz
wenn das wirtschafts fahrer und den
halter muss zwischen immer alles wie
geplant
was willst du denn flügen john hat
sommerferien und verbringt den ganzen
tag zu hause mit seiner mutter william
ist chance bester freund und geht in
dieselbe klasse auch er wohnt in
clearwater aber eineinhalb stunden mit
dem auto entfernt
deshalb hat simone ein play date up
gemacht den sandhaufen hat christian nur
für seinen sohn im garten abgeladen
inzwischen hat sich der sechsjährige
sehr gut eingelebt
simone sorgen schon aus der gewohnten
schweizer umgebung zu reißen sind weit
weg jetzt dort sie und natürlich der
große held reform ist er vor der schweiz
gar nichts und macht glücklich will
dance denkt na gut meist heiter bis
richtig macht mein kind mit schlips
arthur kröten frösche und ein riesiger
abenteuerspielplatz john erobert die
neue heimat
[Musik]
sonne und konstanter wind lassen die
herzen der kitesurfer höher schlagen
hochsaison auf werte ventura
tobias und michael aber haben kaum zeit
die schönen seiten der ferieninsel zu
genießen
41 sie wollen eine gebrauchte
schaufensterpuppe abholen die sie im
internet entdeckt haben also aller welt
die vision heißt du bist sehr schöne tor
soft oder büßen lautete schon sehr große
41 aber weiß nicht wo ich bin tobias wir
kommen wegen des torsos könnten wir ihn
sehen mit der puppe wollen sie das
geschäft mit den t-shirts ankurbeln
michaels boutique läuft noch nicht so
wie geplant nur für damen
aber natürlich darf das wichtige dass
die damen das gut
[Musik]
die beiden müssen immer noch jeden euro
umdrehen ihr budget ist fast
aufgebraucht
[Musik]
die jungs versuchen aus wenig viel zu
machen
in kleinen schritten zum großen geschäft
[Musik]
sogar die gartenpflanzen kommt weg und
zwei der drei gästezimmer sind bereits
geräumt auf bali ist es zeit abschied zu
nehmen
jetzt reist auch beck bäckerin sarah
[Musik]
jetzt gehen wir denn hier
unterm strich dort so gut
[Musik]
was ist mit den leuten
fukushima oder irgendwie bedrückt die
kilometer die sind im prinzip nur einen
korb neid ich habe mit das ist dass ich
das in japan immer noch zweimal fahren
dann haben die mitarbeiter der spedition
alle möbel abtransportiert
ein
[Musik]
hier können wir norden spot for green in
kanada hat christian einen termin mit
seinem auftraggeber chris vom sägewerk
wie sehen ob sich der hang mit der
spezialausrüstung wirklich erschließen
lässt sich teilen blend und deinem
riesige felsen und bürgersteig glück wo
man anlegen
da schaue ich jetzt dort trost dass man
das schnitt gerechnet
im kommenden jahr will das sägewerk
christians auftragsvolumen verdoppeln
die männer brauchen jetzt einen starken
baum an dem sie die seilwinde befestigen
können
dieser muss die last der maschine
während der arbeit halten können
hunger studie
ja der grünen für die heiklen einsätze
ist merkur der chefcoach christian ist
froh ihn an seiner seite zu haben
[Musik]
mirko sekt eine erste schneise in den
hang
[Musik]
bis zu 60 prozent gefälle sollte die
sicherung mit dem stahlseil aushalten
[Musik]
christian hat die salbe in der bis 85
prozent gefälle getestet einmal ist das
seil gerissen
mein die höchste liga vorher fahren also
denke defizit mengen dem landwirt fritz
gabe kann zweiter wurde also sowie
hersteller ich meine so pollen fälle die
template elitären stieg deutsche zoll
größer
also habe ich mit der wir durchschnitten
[Musik]
auf fuerteventura ist das geschäft
unberechenbar manchmal kommt einfach
niemand in den laden dann gibt es auch
kinder offiziell die puppe aus zweiter
hand soll die designlinie mit dem stern
besser zur geltung bringen
die t shirts hat michael entworfen genau
dass man das doch so gut verkauft haben
zwei christine kaffee geht an die ränder
und so hat der ehemals xl xxl braucht
oder auftritt haben haben wir das thema
koffer mit leben und so damit möchte
erst einmal für zwei jahre kommen
[Musik]
nur wenig später ist die bar plötzlich
voll einfach immer da sein und schauen
dass die gäste möglichst lange hier
bleiben
das scheint das beste geschäftsmodell zu
sein ihre spezialität vom
eröffnungsabend bieten sie mittlerweile
nicht mehr an
[Musik]
13 stunden und mehr verbringen die
beiden in ihrem geschäft open end
natürlich und das tag für tag das neue
leben als babel treiber hat auch seine
schattenseiten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nach zehn stunden arbeit den steilhang
räumen christian und seine männer die
maschinen weg
an der kreissäge richtet er die säge
zähne immer wieder neu aus damit sie
scharf bleiben in der weite der rocky
mountains suchte er mehr freiheit für
sich und sein unternehmen sowohl auf und
ab endlich zuhause bereitet simone das
abendessen vor
im angebot sogar schweizer käsefondue
und spirit und da ich jetzt immer wenn
kreieren will der senior und dann
einfach für das muss jetzt sicher auch
landschaft sind und dass alles so gut
gang ist besser wie das man denkt und da
ich glaube dass für eure krise schlicht
simone hatte erst mühe in der neuen
umgebung heimisch zu werden aber langsam
was die fuß und der jetzige situation
dass klar würde ich nun werde druck
hätte sie braucht
ich denke dass ich denke früher zum sehr
gemein ist jetzt wirklich für immer und
ewig ago im moment denke ich es war so
aber ich denke noch überraschen
[Musik]
für christian ist der nächste schritt
klar er möchte für sich und die familie
eine dauerhafte aufenthalts- bewilligung
beantragen
[Musik]
der kanadische boden ist für ihn heimat
geworden
[Musik]
hallo hallo alles klar
wir sind grüßt tagesausklang mit
freunden und praktikanten
das erste jahr ist geschafft
[Musik]
romano und patricia sehen wieder zurück
in der schweiz eine freundin bringt sie
zu ihrem wohnhaus in kesswil dass sie
vorsichtshalber nie gekündigt haben sie
kommen zu einem schlechten zeitpunkt
ausgerechnet jetzt lässt der besitzer
das haus umfassend sanieren
aber sonst wohl fassade fenster heizung
alles wird neu gemacht hab ich bin
trotzdem
[Applaus]
du irgendwie schon früh
es ist noch nicht lange her dass sind
studis von hier aus in ihr abenteuer
gestartet
[Musik]
ein lauer sommerabend in corralejo
michael serviert den gin tonic
also das eigentlich nicht so schwierig
zu machen aber er sieht auch sehr gut
aus 14 vereinen 40 schiff in stars haben
sich urlauber aber auch einheimische
eingefunden
wie immer zwei drei damen die kommen ja
mehrmals pro woche hier und da zu
trinken bis jetzt also am anfang wir
haben unser geschäft dann schon immer
beim anderen und kaffeetrinken und jetzt
gehen wir nur noch bei uns sehr und bin
mit sozialer und bin sozusagen die
stellen ungeachtet dessen er aber ich
habe bestimmt gar nicht zuständigen
erweitern
langsam wachsen michael und tobias in
ihrer rolle als barbetreiber hinein
[Musik]
so
wochenende in clearwater zeit für ein
familienprojekt die volks bauen das alte
siedler haus auf ihrem grundstück zu
einem partyraum um
christian ist mit seinem bagger
vorgefahren das problem
er sieht nicht richtig was er macht
maetzigs zuwachs der jubel für nach der
matur gewandt hatte irgendwie ist
irgendwie vermeiden raten zwischen
aktion und reaktion wieder hinter sich
nicht gut
die familie hat noch viel vor und die 65
hektar land rund um ihr haus wollen
genutzt werden unterschiedlich unserem
projekt als eine hammerhead mal dass ich
da vorne wieder erwartet machte das was
früher einmal da haben wir jetzt alles
gerade das planiert und katja christ
ernst sind immer noch hoch
ich hätte es nicht getan chef oder
schlichte pfarrgasse oder alpakas und
hühner geld von mir wenn gern hat
eigentlich gar soviel sache wo man
könnte und gehören es gern hören
doch das halbe dorf oder ich meine das
jetzt wirklich mal david walsh mache das
mache oskar bewilligung braucht gar
nichts erotisches und verdammt cool ist
[Musik]
noch einmal richtig jetzt auch drüber
ich muss darüber ihre
[Musik]
in schaffhausen auf dem martinimarkt
haben schulden stadt gemietet
romano baut für die zukunft auf das
zweite standbein er will verschiedene
produkte aus bali verkaufen
schon seit sieben wochen sind sie wieder
hier rein klimatechnische hab ich vorher
schon nicht so oft das klima gestanden
[Musik]
jetzt wird diese treue und ich habe
tiere
[Musik]
dies müssen sich in der alten heimat
wieder neu orientieren
die richtige begeisterung verwirrend bis
zu ihrer auswanderung hatte patricia
eine kaderposition inne
sie war bereichsleiterin bei einem
grossverteiler und führte ein team von
acht mitarbeitern kontaktiert und
systeme stellen stellen stand peter
forscht und bin momentan einfach in
basel
für den anfang arbeitet patricia als
zolldeklarant in ab märz ist sie
geschäftsführerin einer kleinen
spedition romano will möglichst nicht
mehr zurück in einen geregelten job
er möchte gerne selbständig bleiben
so also habe ich nur das projekt vom
gästehaus unter palmen ist geplatzt
es hat den alltag auf bali nicht
überstanden aber die sehnsucht nach
einem leben abseits des täglichen trott
es bleibt man rufe die trainer keine
lehrer mehr über 20 an türen auf die
sind jetzt mit einem zug bloss ihre
produkte also und rechtlich sehr gute
erfahrung gemacht dass der nissan und
was wiederum das ich weiß es nicht
also 11 500 kilometer das ist einmal
besonders an grill
die stadt ist einfach zu groß sind die
verrückten studis sie haben nicht nur
vom auswandern gesprochen
sie haben den schritt ins ungewisse
gewagt
immer am mittwochabend tobias und
michael ruhetag
die beiden genießen ihre zweisamkeit
[Musik]
wir sind zusammen hat das folgendes
machen so lange sagt vischer ist
irgendwie also gut getan wie bisher
sechs chancen her ist dann irgendwie
doch blauer gegenüber es vorgemacht
da zeigt sich dass die alte treppe die
chance forscht sowieso nichts wird
geschenkt jeder auch in der schweiz
nicht aber hier noch weniger ja aber je
länger die arbeitszeit also muss man
sagen jetzt mal aus der schweiz kommt
man muss es klar dass man das ist das
andere sagte der ausblick das klima und
so dass das irgendwie u4 wenn das nicht
[Musik]
für den nachmittag haben sie eine buggy
tour gebucht
das wort
potato
[Applaus]
gemeinsam abheben und auf fuerteventura
etwas eigenes auf die beine stellen
für dieses ziel werden tobias und
michael die schweiz verlassen
[Applaus]
sorgen
der weg zur gemeinsamen bawa steinig und
nicht immer leicht beharrlich haben sie
sich in einer fremden umgebung
eingerichtet und ihren traum
verwirklicht auch mit kleinem budget
[Musik]
bringen dass man sich vorher aber das
war einfach zu viel
ja und ich hoffe dann können wir unsere
geschäft noch mit gefällt besten
vergrößern unsere sortiment nochmal
ausbauen wird vielleicht mit ein zweites
geschäft das wäre doch schön windig und
bein und es etwas tribut
nicht alles ist möglich ich sage nur die
bespricht ziel schon mit zetsche war
jetzt mal das ist soll auf das publikum
[Applaus]
[Musik]
muss ich die genivi brücke mit alkohol
kommen
die wiener spö ist offen
[Musik]
allein für alle mit fernweh airline für
mid hw
ich singe präsentiert wurde